Andy wants people to think he's a guy
who cares passionately about American
culture I care that people think I care
yes exactly yeah
so Andy wanted to take just a moment to
address some of the things that everyone
is talking about right now are you ready
for this Andy I'm ready Conan all right
I'm Dee Richter congratulations on the
new us-mexico Trade Agreement major
props to our lead negotiator rot Robert
light hyzer and his Mexican counterpart
ildefonso guardo gmail redesigned its
desktop interface and you got us talking
about it guys great revamp fellas did I
hear right crystal from re-season
went to Paradise to meet Connor from
Becca's season yikes poor Chris a lot of
my co-workers have their fantasy
football drafts this week I want them to
draft the right players so they do the
most points and they're happy that's my
fantasy anyway crazy rich Asians has
made 76 million dollars but will it
surpass the 122 million dollars the GI
Joe retaliation made to become director
John Chows biggest film pumpkin spice
lattes are back in Starbucks tomorrow it
may be 90 degrees outside but when that
first spike of nutmeg and cinnamon hits
my tongue it's going to be autumn in my
mouth
and finally I hope Conan has a terrific
show tonight for one simple reason
Conan's happiness means more to me than
my own
[Applause]
[Music]
you